Hello and
welcome, everyone. This is physics as
information processing, session four on
communicating observers. It's the 10
August 2023. Chris looking forward
to this lecture. Off to you.
Thank you, Daniel, and welcome to this
session. As Daniel said, this is about
out communicating observers. And fasten
your seatbelts because we have a lot to
cover in the next hour.
So just to do a quick review. We've been
talking about quantum information theory
and we've been talking about it in the
simplest possible setting of two
systems, Alice and Bob, that exchange
information through their mutual
boundary. And we've assumed that
everything is finite dimensional. So we
don't need to worry about infinite
energy transfer across this boundary.
And of course, we assume conservation of
energy so there are no sources or sinks
in either of the systems. Alice and Bob
and we emphasize that this way of
depicting things as topological we're
not assuming any background geometry,
no sort of spatial embedding which is
going to become very important in this
session. In the
last session, we talked about how the
boundary, which I'll always call B can
be thought of as a channel that
comprises N qubits that are independent.
And Alice and Bob each can prepare and
measure those qubits and they can always
choose independently their reference
frames for doing so. So how they define
up and down when they're measuring a
spin with effectively a Zspin operator.
To interact with these qubits.
We talked a little bit about the free
energy principle and its quantum
formulation. And the principle basically
says that interacting systems will
behave in a way that aligns their
reference frames and that they therefore
asymptotically approach entanglement.
So the FEP is a classical limit of the
principle of unitarity. And that's one
reason for studying quantum information
to learn more about the FEP and
so to learn more about active inference
and what the theory of active inference
says about agents.
And last time, we talked a lot about the
constraints that are imposed by a
limited free energy supply on any agent.
Recall that we talked about the fact
that in the absence of sources of free
energy within
an agent so as long as you conserve
energy globally that the free energy
that each agent uses has to come from
its environment. That's clearly true for
us. We have to consume oxygen and eat
food and things like that to keep
running as systems. And we discussed
a little bit this theorem that if two
reference frames or quantum processes,
q One and Q Two don't commute,
they have to be implemented by
compartments that communicate
classically. And we'll use this
extensively today. But the bottom line
last time was that physics alone gives
us compartmentalization in systems
whenever the systems are complex enough
to have multiple kinds of measurements
that they can't deploy simultaneously.
So where we're going today,
we're going to start from this place
we left off last time of the possibility
of agents that are compartmentalized and
into compartments that have to
communicate classically. So we're going
to talk about agents that can be
compartmentalized into multiple
subagents that share an environment,
the environment consisting of Bob and
how those agents talk about that shared
environment. So the motivation for this
is simple. It's that what we do all the
time is a group activity. And what we're
doing right now is a group activity that
involves sharing an environment. What's
shown on this screen and talking about
it. And the whole post
session discussion process will be
another example of just that sort of
thing. So to talk about science at
all or to talk about any kind of social
relations or to talk about anything
other than solipsism, we have to be able
to talk about how multiple agents
communicate about some shared
environment. And so that's what we're
going to develop a formal way of talking
about. And there are two things to
notice right off the top about this.
One is that the way we've defined
interactions at boundaries, they're
effectively instantaneous. So each
agent, remember, interacts with its
boundary with some set of operators.
And what those operators do is
effectively measure each operator
effectively measures the spin of a
qubit. So this is a very fast process.
The other thing that we then need to
notice is that if we have two agents
and they're communicating with each
other classically,
then they're going to be using degrees
of freedom of their shared environment
in order to communicate. And that's
exactly what we're doing right now. For
example, we're using degrees of freedom
of the Internet to communicate.
I'm using degrees of freedom of the
local atmosphere to talk to my
microphone and I'm using degrees of
freedom of the local photon field to see
my screen. So all communication
between agents and certainly all
classical communication between agents
uses degrees of freedom of the
environment. And the environment,
remember, is the other system, Bob,
that's on the other side of that shared
boundary. So we're going to be
interested in how components of Alice
use Bob as a communication channel and
in fact, as multiple communication
channels. And I just wanted to quote my
colleague and friend Mike Levin in his
statement that all intelligence is
composite. All of us, all organisms,
even single cells, are composite
systems that comprise many different
agents that are able to make different
kinds of measurements and execute
different kinds of actions and so have
to communicate classically. So we're
talking about all of life here as well
as all of social systems and ecosystems
and such things as that.
So the first thing I want to do today is
simplify the notation so that we don't
have to draw quite such complicated
diagrams. So the picture on the left
here is a picture from the last session.
It shows the structure of a very simple
agent that makes some measurements
using a reference frame called e and
then writes some results of those
measurements to memory using a reference
frame called y. And those two processes
are connected by an internal clock that
ticks between the input process
and the output process. And the clock
tick corresponds to the expenditure of
free energy to write information
irreversibly on the boundary. So the
memories are actually written on the
boundary because that's where classical
information lives in this theory. So you
can think of this whole process from e
through the clock and back to y as a
single quantum process or as a quantum
computation that maps some sector e of
the boundary to some sector Y of the
boundary. And so we can represent it in
this much simpler way that's over on the
right side as some process Q
that maps some sector on the boundary to
some other sector on the boundary. And
formally, that process can be thought of
as a topological quantum field theory.
Topological here is important. It's not
geometric, it doesn't assume an
embedding in space and this will become
critically important later on.
And the operation of that tqft
requires a clock tick or it incorporates
a tick of this internal clock. And we
can do this because we were
able to prove jim Glazeburg
and Tanino Marciano and I were able to
prove last year that we can always
represent a quantum reference frame as a
topological quantum field theory. And
this just illustrates the two kinds of
transformations between quantum
reference frames that are important. We
can take one and divide it into two
pieces that commute or we can
take a two
part reference frame and we can
swap in another part that
doesn't commute with the part that we've
swapped it in for but that does commute
with the remainder of the reference
frame. So here R is the reference
component of some object identification
system and we can swap
in some different way of looking at the
object once we've identified it. So,
for example, if the object that we're
identifying is a box that can measure
both Z spin and X spin,
then P and Q can be the z spin and x
spin settings on that box that allow us
to effectively rotate the filter from
this way to that way so that we measure
vertical spin versus horizontal spin.
And that's really it. I mean, those are
the ways that one can transform quantum
reference frames. Of course, we could do
arbitrarily many compositions of this
kind of transformation to do something
very complicated, but they map very
simply to tqfts with the structure and
you can construct categories out of this
and find a function that's well defined
that maps one category to another. So
it's an example of a nice use of
categorical techniques for solving
a problem that looks difficult but in
fact it's very straightforward.
So using this simplified notation,
it becomes very easy to see that
if we have two systems, alice and Bob on
opposite sides of this boundary and we
perfectly align their quantum reference
frames, which is what the FEP says
they will tend to do,
then they become entangled. And you
can see that they're entangled by seeing
that once the reference frames are
perfectly aligned, they jointly
implement one quantum process.
And jointly implementing one quantum
process just means you're entangled.
The two sides no longer have
conditionally independent states. If one
quantum process, which is time
reversible, information preserving, is
implemented jointly by the two systems.
So a lot of things like this become very
simple when we think of these
processes as just quantum computations
going on inside some system implemented
by some system and how those processes
relate across some boundary. So that's
what we're going to do for studying
communication today.
Another thing to recall from a couple of
sessions ago, our last session, is that
if two reference frames, q one and
Q Two commute, we can always
join them together to form a single
reference frame. And this is just a
graphical depiction in this simpler
language of how that works. And
topologically, there's no distinction
between the left side and the right
side. What I've done is just squeeze the
top two green circles together and the
bottom two green circles together into
one circle. And that just makes a
simple process connecting the top one to
the bottom one. So what we're going to
be interested in is situations where
this doesn't happen, where Alice
consists of two components that execute
reference frames that don't commute.
And so the two components are
conditionally independent. They do each
have free choice of reference frame.
And so they have to communicate
classically. They don't share a
single quantum process, so they're not
entangled. And before
we go ahead to do that, I just
wanted to remind you of some of the
no go theorems that follow from this
situation depicted on the right, where
we have a single agent executing a
single reference frame, a single
process, a single kind of measurement,
any set of commuting measurements that
can be combined into one measurement.
And here are some things Alice can't do.
And we've talked about some of these
previously. So this is basically a
reminder. But Alice
can't, using just one measurement,
measure the entanglement entropy across
her own boundary. So Alice can't know
that she has an independent state. She
can't know that she's not entangled with
Bob. And that's a useful thing to think
about philosophically as it applies to
you and me. We can't actually know that
we have independent states.
Alice can't measure her own entanglement
entropy, so she can't know whether she
has components that have to communicate
classically.
She can't measure Bob's entanglement
entropy, so she can't know whether Bob
has compartments that have to
communicate classically. And if you
think in terms of perception theory,
this says Alice can't know whether Bob
consists of separate objects that behave
classically.
Their behavior can look classical to
her, but she's not able to determine
that their behavior is classical because
she can't measure Bob's entanglement
entropy. She can't measure the
dimension of her own boundary and
recall from a couple of times ago that
the boundary includes some sector that
supplies free energy that Alice can't
extract information from for further
processing, she can only extract free
energy from. So she can't measure the
dimension of that sector, and so she
can't measure the dimension of the whole
boundary itself. And this, of course,
means that she can't measure her own
dimension either. And of course, she
can't measure Bob's dimension, because
the only information she can get about
Bob is the classical information that's
encoded on this boundary. She can't
reach past the boundary to see how large
a system Bob is. And that's
clearly connected to this first point,
that she can't measure the entanglement
entropy across Bob, because the
entanglement entropy can only be small
if her dimension and Bob's dimension are
both much larger than the dimension of
the boundary. So that's a condition she
can't check. So all
of these kind of no go theorems lead off
in interesting directions. And the only
one that we're really going to be
interested in here is
the third one, the one about measuring
Bob's entanglement entropy, because we
want to talk specifically about how
multiple agents, so multiple components
of Alice can access information about
Bob's entanglement entropy.
Okay, so recall from the end of the last
session that the last thing we talked
about was classical communication. And
we talked about the fact that classical
communication involves assumptions and
pitfalls and that we have to be very
careful whenever we talk about it. And
what we're going to do today is standard
practice in physics. We're simply going
to stipulate that these
components, a one and a two, the
separable components of Alice,
communicate classically. And so we're
going to draw it like this. We're going
to draw a classical channel between
them, and that classical channel passes
through Bob. It uses degrees of freedom
of the ambient photon field or the
ambient atmosphere or pieces of paper or
email or something like that that's out
there in the environment to exchange
classical messages. And there are a
couple of things to note here I haven't
even written down here. We're assuming
that a one and a two share some language
for this classical communication.
That's a big assumption, as we talked
about last time. But I
will note explicitly that classical
communication takes time. That's what
defines classicality here. It's causal,
so it can't work faster than the speed
of light. This is a topological theory.
We don't have any embedding geometry.
So we can't, at this point, talk about
light, which is a relationship between
space and time, because we've got time,
we've got clocks, but we don't have any
space. But we can say that
whatever passes through this classical
channel requires at least one clock tick
on Bob's side. So it's a process
that Bob has to execute.
And executing that process takes time.
So getting the signal from me to
you on the internet takes some time. So
the environment's clock has to tick
during that. And all of these
assumptions bundled together turn out to
be a fairly serious set of assumptions
and they involve assumptions about fine
tuning, about the universe being just
right and they
should make us nervous and I just want
to leave it at that. We always assume
with complete a plumb that agents can
communicate classically. But it's not a
straightforward assumption and it's
worth any of you are looking at for
interesting research projects can look
into the nature of classical
communication. It's full of hidden
assumptions and surprises and things
that aren't at all straightforward even
though they look like they ought to be.
So there's a challenge. So why
do we assume this? Why do we assume
classical communication? We do it
because we have to if we're going to
talk about detecting entanglement.
And most of
you probably know the history of the
notion of entanglement. It was first
noticed by Einstein, Podolski and Rosen
ever after called EPR in 1935.
And they wrote a paper which is infamous
and called the EPR Paper in which they
argued that the phenomenon of
entanglement made no sense and couldn't
possibly be physical. And since
quantum theory included this notion of
entanglement, it couldn't possibly be a
complete theory of what's going on in
the world. And Schrodinger replied the
same year with a very detailed paper
where he introduces, among other things,
Schrodinger's cat as a paradox. And he
explains very clearly what entanglement
is and why entanglement follows from
quantum theory. And he uses that
discussion to argue that the classical
notion of a physical state is not
actually applicable to the world as it
is. So he answers the EPR paper very
directly. And this
discussion is
currently mostly known as the Bohr
Einstein debate because of course Bohr
already in 1928 has said had said in
print that the classical notion of
causality in space and time simply
doesn't apply anymore. And Einstein
objected to that vigorously. But that
was 1935 and it was almost 50 years
later that entanglement was first
observed in the laboratory. Here the
1982 picture is a picture of the
interior of Alan Aspet's laboratory when
he performed the first entanglement
experiment for which he finally won the
Nobel Prize last year.
And these days this kind of experiment
is done all over the world and is even
done with satellite borne sources.
Resource is the key to quantum
secured communication, as we'll discuss
in quantum cryptography and quantum
banking and the quantum internet, all
this other stuff that you may have heard
of. So before
talking more about these experiments,
I just want to provide
a definition of entanglement.
Entangled simply means not separable.
That's the definition. So a state, a
joint state AB is entangled if and only
if it does not factor into
two separable states.
And that's it. That's the definition.
And the literature,
and especially the popular literature,
is absolutely rife with hype and various
kinds of mischief of entanglement and
authors trying to convince you that
entanglement is this amazing
kind of woo woo thing.
And whenever you run across that, go
back to the definition, entanglement
simply means this simple mathematical
condition of not separability or a
state that isn't factorizable. And that
means that the state does not display
classical conditional independence. So
classically, that's the way to think
about it. It's a failure of conditional
independence. And it's ubiquitous in
quantum theory, even though it wasn't
actually absurd for almost 50 years
after it was predicted.
So here's what all these experiments
look like. They're called Bell EPR
experiments, after John Bell,
who derived the statistical criterion
for detecting entanglement and EPR.
Einstein, Podolski and Rosen, who did
this as a thought experiment and said,
if this occurs in the theory, it can't
possibly be real. And of course it is
real. It's now amply demonstrated by
experimentation. Here's how they work.
There's a source. The source produces a
state that is entangled.
And I've written the typical what's
called a Bell state. It's up plus or
minus down divided by the square root of
two just to normalize it. But up plus or
minus down is clearly not the same as up
times down. So this is not a separable
state. And this state propagates outward
in space and time to two observers who
have independent laboratories, for
example, on different continents. In
that space based experiment that I
showed you the picture of from the COVID
of Science a few years ago, 2017, I
think, the Tulip observers have freedom
to choose their own reference frame,
their own Z axis for measuring spin.
They do a spin measurement, and they do
this over and over and over again. They
accumulate statistics and they exchange
their results so that they can analyze
the joint statistics of their
experiment. And they check to see
whether that joint statistics is
consistent with classical probability
theory. And if it isn't to
a statistically significant level, then
they've been able to detect
entanglement. Now, notice that this
process requires classical
communication. They have to make their
independent measurements in their own
laboratories, and then they have to
exchange results, or one of them has to
send results to the other one, or they
both have to send their results to some
third party. But in all of these cases,
they're exchanging some classical data.
And so we have the assumption that
whoever gets that classical data knows
the language it was recorded in and so
can do a joint analysis.
So I'll just show you another picture of
this experiment that's in a standard
space time diagram here. Time is
vertical, space is horizontal.
The two observers are labeled Alice and
Bob. They share a quantum channel
that goes from Alice to the source to
Bob. That's the entangled state.
They do some processing. And then one of
them here, Bob, sends the results to
Alice. And that's a classical
communication. It takes time, and it
traverses space. So this step
is classical. So this is why we have to
assume classical communication to talk
about detecting or using entanglement.
So now I want to represent this in a
different way. Using our little
picture earlier. We're going to think of
Alice, again as two components, a one
and a two. They're separable, so they
have to communicate classically. They
have a classical channel that goes
through Bob, and they also now share
some quantum channel. They share an
entangled state. And the entangled
state, of course, is produced by Bob.
The source is part of Bob. And their
detectors, if you want to think about it
that way, are located on this boundary
B, or their interface with the sources
on this boundary B. And each of them
executes a process that accumulates
data from the quantum channel and
communicates it to the other observer
via the classical channel. Now,
this picture illustrates what's called a
lock protocol. Lock means local
operations and classical communication.
So a one and a two are each operating
locally on their boundary. They're
making measurements locally on their
boundary, and they're communicating via
actions locally on their boundary and
observations locally on their boundary.
So, for example, I'm communicating with
my computer here. We can consider it my
boundary. And stuff is happening in the
environment that's implemented by the
Internet, and you're receiving those
communications locally on your boundary,
on your laptop or whatever it is you're
using. So that's what local operations
means. And these protocols
specifically involve classical
communication. And so they're able to
detect entanglement. And a Bell EPR
experiment is just an example of a lock
protocol. The observers exchange
information about how they're going to
do their experiments. They're both going
to measure D spin. They're going to use
independently chosen reference frames,
and they're going to look at the output
from some agreed upon source.
So that's all classically set up.
Then they actually make their
observations, and then they classically
communicate their results. So classical
communication front and back lock
protocols are not limited to this sort
of Bell EPR sort
of setting. We can also represent a
scattering experiment as a lock
protocol. So here's
a representation of scattering as a lock
protocol. And you can see all I've done
is cut that previous
boundary at the division between a
one and a two. And I've then extended it
in some external time,
the time that is counted by
Bob's clock, not by Alice's clock.
That's what's meant by external.
And I've relabeled Alice two as Alice
one at a later time. So now what Alice
is doing is communicating with her past
self, or a one is communicating with
her future self, and they're each
doing something different. A one is
executing a procedure that in the
laboratory we call state preparation.
She's preparing a state that we'll call
in, which is just the initial state
of some scattering experiment. So, for
example, at the LHC,
N is some state of two protons that
are portaling around the ring at the LHC
at close to the speed of light.
And Alice, then later
on at T plus delta, t is
doing a different kind of quantum
process. She's analyzing the data coming
out of something like the Atlas
detector, which is a multiparticle
counter that's located at the LHC.
So they share a quantum channel, which
is the scattering channel that takes the
incoming state and produces the outgoing
state. And I recall
from the very first session, as Feynman
told us, to understand this transition
from in to out, we have to integrate
over all possible paths that are
consistent with conservation of spin.
Holicity basically momentum plus spin.
All the different spins that are
relevant in a high energy physics
experiment, including things like Lepton
number, which is basically a spin.
Now, how do we know? How do we know what
we have to conserve? We know what we
have to conserve because Alice is doing
the experiment has a classical memory
that allows her to remember what she
prepared. She can remember that what she
did back in the past was
set to protons counterrotating in the
LHC, and they had certain energies,
and so they had certain momenta, and
they were protons, so they had certain
spin variables. All of that has to be
remembered to make any sense of the
output of the detectors. And so
to actually come up with a measured
state that makes sense. And very
often this memory channel is neglected
by physicists. And I'm going to pause
here and let Andrew ask a question.
Thank you, Chris. So does this imply
that every time you have a log channel,
the quantum part is a
scattering picture, like a unitary
evolution? Even in the earlier EPR
picture, is that quantum channel portion
always a unitary evolution scattering
picture? Thank you.
Yes, for essentially
the reason that defined
a classical channel, you're always
assuming you have something that's
protected from decoherence by the
environment. So,
yeah, if you're doing an EPR experiment,
you have to assume that you don't have
any environmental decoherence between
the source and the detectors. And
similarly, when you're doing a
scattering experiment, you have to make
the assumption that the environment
is not reaching in there and messing
with the outgoing state that you're
going to see, or reaching in and messing
with the incoming state and changing it
in some way that repepes it in
a way that you don't know, that you have
no knowledge of. So, yes, you're making
a fairly strong antidecornce assumption
in any of these settings when you're
talking about having a quantum channel.
Does that answer the question? Yes.
Thank you. Okay, great.
So we can think of lock,
we can think of scattering as Locke,
and I just wanted to now emphasize that
effectively. What Locke is implementing
is two parallel memories. A classical
memory, which, as we said in the case of
scattering, is memory for preparation.
In the EPR case, it's memory for
preparation for what the experimental
setup is, for what the instructions for
doing the experiment are.
And we also have a quantum channel,
which is effectively another memory.
It's something that's extended through
time. And again, it's implemented by
the environment, implemented by Bob,
and it involves Bob's. Clock ticking.
So whenever we have two memories
in parallel, we can construct an error
correcting code. So think of a simple
classical error correcting code.
For example, the use of parity bits in
exchanging digital data. So if I send
you a bit string classically,
and I send it to you two or three times,
so there's some redundancy in my signal
and I send you a parity bit, I say,
okay, add up your bit string, and the
result should be one. It's one on my
side. If you add it up and you
get zero, there's an error someplace.
You can use that parity bit to detect
errors. So you can throw out the
bit strings that you receive that have
parity of zero and say, oh, the
environment interfered somehow with the
signal, or some eavesdropper interfered
with the signal. It made a mistake, or
something like that. So this corresponds
to environmental decoherence not being a
good assumption. Even though it's
classical, environmental interference is
not a good assumption in this case.
So a quantum error correct encoder is
basically the same idea. I use some
feature of the fact that I have two
different memories and that
I'm encoding something in time.
I'm encoding multiple replicates of
something in time to provide
a way of checking to make sure that I'm
sending the correct message.
So I can, for example,
consider the message to be my classical
memory and consider the quantum process
as a process that tests that memory.
So I remember that I need to do
experiment X, and I will get result Y.
I actually do experiment X on
this quantum channel and see if I get
result Y. And if
I don't get result Y, then something's
wrong. Either I can't trust the quantum
channel or I've remembered my
preparation conditions incorrectly. So
I'm using one memory to check the
accuracy of the other. And this using
something about the environment, some
channel in the environment to check
memory is absolutely ubiquitous,
and we use it all the time.
So, for example, look around your room,
and your room hopefully looks more or
less the same now that it did at the
start of this session.
And that's very reassuring.
It reassures you that something's not
happening in the environment that's
dangerous and disturbing. And if you
couldn't do that, if your environment
was constantly changing and there was no
familiarity about the environment, you
wouldn't be able to check your memory.
You wouldn't be able to. Check your
sanity. So even though we don't think
about our local environments as
effectively an error correcting code,
that's exactly how we use it. We use
stigmurgic memory or memory out there in
the environment as a way of checking our
own memories and assuring that our
memory is okay.
So I talked a little bit about quantum
security. Here's how quantum security
system works again. It's a lock
protocol. We have some classical
signal that can be thought of as a code
or a key or a
one time pad, for example, that encodes
a way of doing experiments. And once
that's been exchanged, assuming it's
secure, then we can use the quantum
channel to communicate information. And
the classical channel has told us what
we have to do with that quantum channel.
We have to make certain kinds of
measurements at, say, particular clock
times as measured. And we'll get
information sent from the
past, from the sender.
And the classical channel protects
the quantum channel from adversarial
agents, because anything that an
adversarial agent does to the quantum
channel, if some agent tries to
eavesdrop, for example, on the quantum
channel, they'll disrupt the quantum
channel. And the results of our
measurement will not be what's
expected given the protocol that we run,
that we have run. So quantum
communication is secured by the fact
that interfering with some entangled
state actually destroys the state so
it's detectable. We can always know
if someone is trying to disrupt our
communications, which isn't true if we
just have two classical channels.
Charlie can always intercept a message
and then recreate it. And that's not
possible with the quantum channel.
So let's refold this diagram
so that we've taken the external time
back out of it.
And we have this picture where the two
components of Alice are just interacting
via their shared boundary with their
environment. Bob and now we can see that
the source of redundancy is not time,
it's the boundary itself.
Just sharing the boundary allows
Alice's components, a one and a two,
to put copies of the same information
on different places on the boundary.
So the boundary now becomes a resource
for redundant storage of information.
So Alice one and Alice two can use
different parts of the boundary to
check what other parts of the boundary,
say, to check the information that's
encoded on other parts of the boundary
so they can define an error correct
encode on the boundary itself using
this lock protocol.
So I just want to leave you with this
idea that using
classical and quantum channels together
allows us to define error
correcting codes on boundaries that we
share as separate agents and
leave you to think about what
shared measurements, what shared quantum
reference frames let us as agents
see the same things.
And this is what we'll talk about next
time in September. We'll talk
specifically about how space provides
us with an error correcting code and
try to understand why space
is treated as emergent from something
else, basically from communication in
most of quantum gravity. So thank you
very much. I encourage you to use the
interactive QA and to attend the
discussion sessions, and we'll see you
in September. Thank you.
Awesome. Chris,
thank you for the lecture. Andrew, do
you have any remarks or
questions? Not right now, thank you.
I'll just ask a few quick questions and
if anyone has one, quickly in the live
chat. So you mentioned the tick of the
clock, and in active inference,
we often hold up side by side both the
discrete time models and the continuous
time models. So do clocks have to tick
discreetly or how do we think about
continuous time modeling.
In this quantum setting? They do have to
tick discreetly because one has to
be able to distinguish Alice's
preparation of the qubits on her
boundary from Bob's measurements of the
qubits on the boundary.
And this
process can be extremely fast with
respect to any kind of sense of
macroscopic time.
Your eyes are responding to photons in,
I think it's hundreds of femtoseconds.
So the discrete transitions
that are effectively time measurements
for you are at that very fast molecular
timescale, much, much faster than our
typical clocks. Now,
when we try to do very fast timing,
we're constructing a faster clock than
that, but it's a clock that we can only
observe indirectly.
Awesome. Okay. Now this one maybe
connects a little bit to application,
but with all the developments happening
in theory, some of which you're
reviewing here and also in practice with
quantum computation, and then keeping in
mind this distinction sorry, I've lost
you back.
I've lost you, Daniel. Okay, we'll wait
till you're back. I can see you. No.
Okay. All right. Just repeat.
Yeah. So so given these rapid and
ongoing developments in theory and
practice related to quantum information
science and quantum information
security, how are people using this
distinction of the classical stigmagic
memory and then the quantum cognitive
process to anticipate how
to develop information systems that are
reliable going forward?
I don't know of any instances in
which thinking about quantum cognition
has entered directly into any design of
communication systems.
The ability of humans to interact with
these systems is just assumed.
So it's just assumed that the user
can interact with, say, a computer
interface, which is the sort
of interface that will be provided or is
provided to any quantum computer. So if
you think about a quantum computer, a
practical quantum computer, it has
classical interfaces front and back.
So in thinking about
interacting with the computer, I'm
giving it some classical problem
statement, for example, and asking for
some classical answer. And what it's
going to give me is a probability
distribution of classical answers.
But I can, by running the calculation
many times, make that probability
distribution fairly tight.
Yeah, I don't know of anyone talking
about quantum BCIs at this point. It'd
be an interesting question.
Was it always understood these
sorts of blind spots and axioms
associated with classical communication.
Was it developed as kind of like a
proposal or like a special case and more
unpacking was left for later? Or are
these blind spots things that we're now
coming into awareness of? Given what
we're learning in the quantum
information sciences? I think we're
learning how serious they are.
But they were certainly recognized even
by Bohr in his 1928 paper.
And that's a very good
paper, too. It's called the present
state of quantum theory or something
like that. And it's in Nature, and it's
available on the web somewhere.
I have a copy of it. But it was written,
in a sense, as Bohr's summary of the
1927 Solve Conference, which was the
conference at which everyone doing
quantum theory at that time got together
to talk about their results. And in
it, Bohr essentially presents what
came to be the Copenhagen
interpretation, which I
think is probably unfairly
called an interpretation. It's sort of
the Copenhagen Pragmatic stance toward
quantum theory. And essentially what
Bohr says is that
if we're going to do science,
we have to assume that people can talk
to each other. And if we're going to
do science, we have to assume that there
are instruments that we can manipulate
and have reasonable confidence that we
know what manipulation we've done. So if
I turn a knob from one to two, I have
to be reasonably confident that I'm
making a particular change that I can
understand. And we have to
have reasonable confidence that
different laboratories can replicate the
same experiment. And if we
think about any of those assumptions in
purely quantum theoretic terms,
then all sorts of questions are raised,
right? Every quantum system is unique.
We have the no Cloning theorem, so every
scientific instrument is unique.
So there's no such thing as exactly
replicating an experiment. Right?
That's a coarse grained description of
what I've done with a completely unique
quantum system. And my brain, of course,
is unique, and yours is too.
And everyone else's is. So talking
about us sharing a language is
essentially a coarse grained assumption.
And what the Copenhagen stance is all
about is coarse graining yielding
effective classicality? Or what that
really means is coarse graining yielding
a description that we can use in the
language that we understand? So these
are very, very old issues that
have been recognized for a long time,
but I think in part because of the
disaster of shut up and calculate,
they haven't really been talked about in
the classroom.
Awesome. I'll just read short questions
from the chat. We can pass them to the
discussion section, but there's a lot of
great diverse questions. So Alexi wrote,
I think I've lost you again. The revenge
of zoom. Well, we looked at the chart
earlier where, like, Bob was talking to
Alice, the Unidirectional.
Okay, okay. The Unidirectional. The
third party is recording it, I'm sure.
Alexi wrote, regarding the environment
being used for error correction, a
symptom of derealization in
psychological trauma breakdown. We don't
recognize the environment around us and
it's scary.
Makes sense. Makes sense. All right.
From Bala. Nice presentation. I heard
Chris say entangled states are LOCC
for a specific reference frame. Is this
entanglement unitary or is it related to
the numbers of degrees of freedom?
I think the quick answer would be both.
If you have a complex system with many
degrees of freedom, some can be
entangled while others aren't.
It depends on what parts of the state
are separable. So again,
entanglement is just a statement about
components of a joint state that factor
or don't.
So you can have a joint state that looks
separable along some dimensions, but in
other dimensions. The other big
complication here is that whether a
state looks entangled depends on the
reference frames that you use to measure
it with. And if
you pick entangled reference frames,
then what we ordinarily think of as
separable, as entangled states become
separable. So you can move entanglement
around.
Awesome. Okay, from Roland Rodriguez is
the discrete temporality only within the
context of a given holographic screen
interface with time being bracketed
otherwise beyond interface systems, is
continuity or discretion kept agnostic?
I think if I understand the question
correctly, it's yes. If I
don't draw any boundaries, I just have
the joint state, then the evolution is
unitary and in
a sense time plays no role. And if
unitary evolution is perfectly time
symmetric, so time actually drops out
altogether. Awesome. So to
talk about time, we have to draw
boundaries. Awesome. Time must have a
stop huxley. And I'll ask
one last question from the appropriately
monikered question quanderer all
communication is abductive is a
sentiment that I've been using to
develop some arguments. Does that scan
for you? How do we connect what we're
discussing here with quantum to
abductive logic?
Yeah,
I could go along with that. I'd want a
lot more detail.
All communication is essentially
analogical. I would agree with that.
Yes. Andrew?
Yes. Thank you. So going back to the
picture where the scattering picture?
So we have so far everything is
topological and certainly
induces breaking the boundary in
different sectors. I suppose it induces
a topology on the boundary. Now, I had a
couple of questions as for the geometry,
and this might be getting ahead.
Is it an emergent property of those
channels between different boundary
sectors? And if that's the case, then
what does it mean to have a QRF or
space?
Yeah, this is really the topic for
September, but you
do point out the fact that it's
something of a chicken and egg
situation. The way
I think of it is, I suppose to choose
the chicken side and think about what
kind of reference frame does the agent
have to implement to
see space on their boundary.
And the reason I think about it that way
is that's a question? I want to be able
to ask about biological systems. And
this actually gets into probably what
won't be talked about till October. But
I want to be able to ask essentially
a phylogenetic question of what
sorts of organisms, where in the lineage
from Luca do we
find systems that are able to assign
spatial coordinates to their boundaries
and what coordinates come first? And I
suspect that sort
of discrete location names with no
metric come first that
a system can talk about, for example,
this part of their membrane versus that
part of their membrane without even
having any ability to say, how far apart
they are and that some sort of
metric representation of this angular
space comes later and that
a radial space comes even later than
that. That's, at this point,
speculation. But I think these are
questions that we can end up asking
given the right kind of formalism and
the right understanding of what it means
to be able to make a spatial
measurement. So the conjecture is that
the metric would emerge from a discrete
network metric of counting ticks sort of
thing. Yeah, I think that's correct.
And the sort of
symmetries of space that we see are very
much tied up with object identity. So if
we think about something like rotational
symmetry let's see,
I should stop screen sharing.
So I've got this object, right,
and I can do this, and I say, oh, space
has this rotational symmetry.
But for me to say that, I have to
recognize that this is the same object,
right? I have to implement object
persistence, which we all learn to do
when we're nine months old or something.
But we tend to regard those as
separate things as we
learn object persistence, because space
is rotationally symmetric, but we can
view it the other way around, that space
is rotationally symmetric for me because
I implement these constraints that are
called object persistence.
Do you think we can understand
phylogenetics as a whole, as a
kind of scattering experiment, like the
high energy Leuka event and
then dissipating and propagating in a
very tangled bank?
Well, I do want to be able to understand
phylogeny in exactly the same terms as
embryology, and Mike Levin and I have
published papers about that. We should
be able to view the lineage of Luca in
exactly the same way that we view the
lineage of the Zygote that produced us.
So that's why it's no coincidence that
during pregnancy, the development of the
embryo mirrors evolution in terms of the
parts that are developed first. Yeah,
this is the old idea that phylogeny and
ontogeny are related in some way,
which, from an embryonic development
point of view, they're certainly
analogous in ways.
Sorry, if I may ask one last question,
things should be very quick regarding
the weak rotation. I'm still a bit
unsure how it ties to this diagrammatic
notation that we had with quantum
channels on show so on.
In the second session, we briefly talked
about the weak rotation being
a reversal in the direction of time. Is
there any relation to today's session?
Yeah,
whenever we think about the
flow of time as driven by
the input output cycle the
input output cycle? For agents separated
by a boundary, there's always a
sign change. Right. My input is your
output, and vice versa. So when
we think about the bob's
clock ticking, when Alice does
something,
his direction of time,
in a sense, points with respect to the
boundary opposite to hers,
but that's only with respect to the
boundary. He sees information flowing
in, and she sees information flowing in.
That's the only point being made here
about the WIC rotation as an operation.
Thank you. Thank you, Chris.
Very well appreciated by the viewers
and by us. So we'll certainly look
forward to reviewing the q a, and
everybody is welcome and encouraged to
join for the participatory discussion in
about two weeks on Saturday. So till
next time. All right, thank you.